[Musique]
je vais tout casser
pas de panique fait les plats prise va
très bien il fait la voix française de
son personnage dans les mondes de ralph
et ça va d'abord parce que moi j'ai des
amis qui ne m'ont jamais reconnu son
talent au cinéma qui ont vu le film
puis quelqu'un ont vu l'affiché avec
monty en fait et on se profile face te
voilà on vient dans la ville de vanier
est en droit des morts le doublage est
un métier de l'ombre qui est exigeant il
faut lire chaque tirage jusqu'à la ligne
rouge et garder le bon rythme bienvenue
au bar de recherche que cherchez-vous
aujourd'hui benoît brière et plus
expérimentés il a entre autres fait la
voix d'un robben une audience dans le
film robot est passé dont là c'est super
c'est quoi la nouvelle j'ai réussi tant
bien que mal la fin du round robin monia
en dessin animé pis c'était le début
d'un trade incroyable
il ya des gens et je les comprends
qu'ils ont choisis sont des acteurs des
actrices de renom qui avaient des
carrière fabuleuse visuel ça dure on les
voyait ok ils y ont des carrières
fabuleuse de doublage parce que là
dessus parce qu'ils ont du fun à faire
ça et c'est un métier c'était super
vraiment super bon on a tout juste le
temps de faire quelques retouches avant
qu'on fasse ton point de vue baj
chaque année environ 650 membres de
l'union des artistes font du doublage au
québec en 2008
ils ont reçu un total de 8,5 millions de
dollars à cacher il ya eu un sommet en
2014 et en 2017 ces artistes ont reçu
9,8 millions de dollars
mais attention la compétition de
l'étranger est féroce et elle vient de
l'espagne où une espèce de
mondialisation en fait du doublage puis
si vous parlez de l'espagne mais la
belge
fort bon tarif qui nous font mal la
france est un énorme bassin double aussi
la france pas bien loin de la belgique
ça se promènent you lie israël
les artistes d'ici ont accepté les
baisses de 15 8% dans certains cas juste
pour être une meilleure compétition
mondiale
tout ce qu'il y avait en plus de payer
les acteurs il faut payer les studios et
vous allez voir chaque doublage est un
investissement important ça peut coûter
entre 40 et 60 mille dollars
dépendant du film chaque film est
différent qui a combien de personnes en
femme de vous parler
il est parfois difficile de convaincre
certains producteurs d'utiliser des
voies d'ici par exemple en 2014 netflix
avait préféré la france pour la
troisième saison de house of cards en
2030 ce sera plus de la moitié 62 cents
on avait eu ces conteneurs par des
brokers à los angeles quand ils ont vu
naître l'extrait france son parti
tranquille mais il donne du travail le
broker et de blogueurs nous en envoie
commence à nous en envoyer le doublage
au québec a vécu plusieurs crises dont
celle de 1997 lui des militaires pour
une loi protectionniste interdisant
qu'on projette sur nos écrans les
doublages réalisé en france
pour l'instant il n'y a aucune
réglementation qui oblige à faire
doubler au québec les films ou les
séries télé c'est une bataille éternelle
c'est une battante qui est relié ni plus
ni moins à la culture québécoise c'est
difficile de faire comprendre il y en a
qu ils le comprennent très bien où on
est et on en est fort heureux c'est ce
qu'on appelle le darknet ici louis fait
depuis mai radio-canada mort et arrive
ne regarde pas son petit frère ou un
petit frère
[Musique]